over the years the mcu has grown and so
have some of its stars do you remember
young thor how about thanos little green
daughter keep watching to see what these
young stars look like today
tony stark's funeral was a who's who of
mcu characters but among the throng of
superheroes was a random teenage boy
that few people seemed to recognize
when the avengers end game credits
rolled and the name tai simkins appeared
however fans quickly figured out that
this was the same boy who helped stark
out of a tight spot back in iron man 3.
simkin's harley keener gave the battered
billionaire a place to hide while on the
run offering him shelter and everything
he needed to repair his armor nobody
imagined that he would show up in
avengers endgame years later but there
he was grieving for stark alongside the
franchise's stars speaking to inverse
the actor revealed that he called robert
downey jr as soon as he heard marvel
wanted him back
the jurassic world star revealed i was
talking to him a little bit about how
excited i am to be in the film and how
much the character of iron man meant to
me through my entire life it was a huge
moment for simkins but the trouble was
he was informed of stark's impending
death back in 2017 when such information
was highly classified he shared that's
two years to keep that secret it was the
hardest thing so why did marvel bring
him back rumor has it that simpkins will
take on the mantle of iron lad in the
future young avengers movie he told ign
that if it were to happen he would love
it
the kid who portrayed the young thor had
quite the resume prior to his mcu
appearance dakota goyo's parents put him
forward for commercials when he was
still an infant and he was right at home
in front of the camera he made his tv
debut at the age of five and would land
his first major film role the following
year delivering a noteworthy performance
in 2007's resurrecting the champ the
six-year-old was nominated for a young
artist award for his turn in the samuel
l jackson sports drama over the next few
years he would star in 2007's emotional
arithmetic 2009's defender and 2011's
real steel but one of his most memorable
experiences was acting alongside anthony
hopkins goyo told light's camera jackson
about working with hopkins who portrayed
thor's father odin he said he is such a
great guy and a legendary movie star
getting the chance to work with someone
like anthony hopkins doesn't come every
day it's certainly something i never
thought i'd get to do
so be it
goyo followed up his role in thor with
an emmy nominated performance in r.l
stein's the haunting hour and would go
on to appear in several more feature
films before he vanished from hollywood
in 2014 those roles included lead parts
and dark skies and the journey home
along with a portrayal of the young
version of russell crowe's noah in the
biblical epic of the same name long
before wyatt olive played stanley yuris
in the it movies and pot loving high
schooler stanley barber in netflix's i
am not okay with this he portrayed the
young peter quill in 2014's guardians of
the galaxy he's since become one of the
brightest young stars in hollywood but
that will come as little surprise to the
people who worked with him on james
gunn's film
crew member simon hatt told the
hollywood reporter have you ever seen
the audition tape of henry thomas for
elliott and e.t
it was like that but way better wyatt's
performance was so real so raw and so
moving i remember being on set and the
whole crew were blown away by him how
did such a young actor turn in such a
convincing performance
he recalled how he felt when his pet
shitsu died olaf said i used that to
help me cry and actually feeling myself
in that situation if that was my mom on
that bed i can feel how powerful that
would be and how awful it would be to
lose someone it wasn't just a one-off
either gunn wanted several takes of the
pivotal scene and oliv nailed them all
hat recalled wyatt gave a stellar
performance with each take he's an
absolute pro and a great collaborator
he's gone bud
abby ryder fortson already had a couple
of credits to her name when she debuted
scott lang's daughter cassie in 2015's
ant-man she had her first tv role in an
episode of the mindy project in 2013
then recurred as ella novak on
transparent during 2014. but she was
still just a shy little girl when she
joined the mcu family speaking to
champagne living ahead of ant-man's
release she discussed her relationship
with paul rudd and revealed that ant-man
and black widow were her favorite
avengers one of the highlights of the
shoot was getting to try on part of the
ant-man suit in wardrobe it sounds like
fortune had an absolute blast on set and
audiences definitely enjoyed her
performance she put in another
scene-stealing turn in the 2018 sequel
ant-man and the wasp by this point she'd
already established herself as a child
star with recurring roles on the spooky
spielberg produced drama the whispers
and hbo comedy togetherness
entertainment weekly dubbed her tv's
most valuable kid though fortune
continues to pop up on the big screen
too her last feature film was 2019's a
dog's journey the post-blip cassie lang
was played by older actor emma furman
but fortune clearly has a bright future
ahead of her
avengers infinity wars ariana greenblatt
was already a child star when she
stepped into the green skin of gamora
daughter of thanos i'm sorry little one
the gifted youngster made her debut in a
2015 episode of disney's live and maddie
making a lifelong friend out of star
dove cameron in the process greenblatt
told entertainment tonight liv and
maddie was my first gig i ever booked
dove has been the sweetest ever since
she's so kind to me and she's like a big
sister you know the future marvel actor
wound up starring in another disney show
taking on the role of mischievous little
sister daphne diaz in stuck in the
middle she appeared in over 50 episodes
between 2016 and 2018 working on her
film resume all the while she made her
movie debut in 2017's a bad mom's
christmas playing the daughter of mila
kunis's bow we may never see her as
gamora again but will definitely be
seeing plenty of green black in the next
couple of years she's in the disney
movie the one and only ivan and the
netflix thriller awake
up and coming young actor kylan davis
actually worked on two marvel films in
2015 one of which was a complete
disaster he played a school bully in
josh trank's much-maligned fantastic
four that same year he also appeared in
ant-man as a member of the family that
gets an unexpected visit from darren
cross aka yellowjacket his scene pops up
in the middle of the big action sequence
at the end of the movie he and his
sister get quite the shock when the
film's villain erupts from their
swimming pool ruining their game of
table tennis and sending their backyard
barbecue into chaos the mississippi-born
actor went on to land a role in matthew
mcconaughey's historical western free
state of jones in 2016. since then he
has managed to carve out a career in
television he played sean campbell and
fox's shots fired in 2017 and followed
that up with a role in the hit netflix
show raising dion in 2019.
more recently he's been seen as jordan
atwater the brother of kevin atwater on
nbc's chicago pd ben sakamoto has
changed dramatically since he made his
debut as hawkeye's eldest son in 2015's
avengers age of ultron cooper barton is
a floppy-haired kid who clings to his
dad when he unexpectedly turns up at the
family safe house with his fellow
avengers in tow the arrow shooting hero
is clearly filled with a deep love for
his wife lara and his kids he goes to
great lengths to keep them safe which
makes it all the more tragic when
they're all turned to dust by thanos we
get to see the fate of hawkeye's family
in 2019's avengers end game sakamoto
returned his cooper for the
heartbreaking scene playing catch with
his little brother moments before they
slip out of existence he had grown up
since his turn in avengers age of ultron
and he was bigger still when he reprised
his role on hawkeye in 2021 in fact he
actually looks taller than jeremy renner
in some scenes the young actor appears
in four episodes of hawkeye making the
disney plush show his biggest acting gig
to date in fact cooper barton is the
only character he's played
many of the actors who played peter
parker's classmates in 2017's spider-man
homecoming got to reprise their roles in
the globetrotting 2019 sequel spider-man
far from home however josie toda wasn't
among them as tom holland and crew
filmed the highly anticipated follow-up
in locations around europe toda was on a
journey of her own a far more personal
one
the actor was grateful to be starring in
the mindy kaling produced comedy
champions but she was struggling with
her identity at the time she decided to
come out as transgender in 2018
revealing that her pronouns are she her
and hers in a guest article for time
magazine
she explained i identify as female
specifically as a transgender female and
my name is josie toda her marvel days
may be over but today's career has been
flourishing since her transition she's
recurred as lisa haddad on the netflix
dramedy no good nick and starred
alongside lisa kudrow in the tv movie
good people
she also appeared in amy poehler's third
feature film moxie which is an
adaptation of jennifer matthews young
adult novel of the same name
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]